hello I'm Ryan Johnson hi everybody I'm
Chandra Bose my name is Paul Masco and
This is Love Letters love letters Love
Letters from letterboxed
right there a little mood change
[Music]
I'm gonna open this up and
find out what this letter says past 103
minutes of my life wow I think it's safe
to say that all was quiet in my living
room after watching this masterpiece you
are too kind I love the songs crying
face
but I am having a smiling face here we
as a culture must let Paul mascal dance
he's probably referencing the Under
Pressure sequence with some questionable
dad dancing and I agree I feel like we
as a culture must let me dance even
though I'm not that good at this heck
yeah
yeah theaters for a third time and I'll
do it again this time was laser focused
on the editing of Eddie Hamilton and
Chris Levinson those two guys kept it
tight thank you very much that's awesome
thank you very much that
f
Wolff was terrifyingly hot this person
saying the wolf is hot is not the only
person saying that the real star was
Angela bassett's hair I'm sure Camille
will love that the real star was Angela
bassett's hair I like that one it was
such a transition from the first one
where she had the long locks and I'm
just so happy that people loved it and
enjoyed it here's the beautiful thing
about all of this Todd field has no
interest and easy answers Tara is a
movie that trusts the intelligence of
its viewers that demands attention to
detail and wants to start a discussion
rather than tell you what to think or
how to feel thank you Marianne well
letterbox is a big part of our cinematic
life or something that I I read quite a
bit and that I feel like I learned from
a twisty turny tail with a sharply
written script and featuring Daniel
Craig and what seems to be his favorite
role Glass Onion was a ton of fun oh
Deirdre he is having a ton of fun when
he plays Benoit Blanc and that means
it's a good environment on set that
means everyone's having a good time and
that's what we want I know Michelle yo
was gonna give an amazing performance
which she absolutely did but it was
kihui Kwan who's still with the show
the innocence in his character
and at the same time the badass version
of his character is portrayed
brilliantly by him he was terrific all
the kindness that you all have shown me
has really won my heart you have made
this a really emotional Journey for me
so I thank you from the bottom of my
heart
[Music]